[Music]
and now we'd like to move
on something else dominic cummings said
yesterday he should have resigned
in september he said after his advice to
have a circuit breaking lockdown
was rejected he said the prime minister
had started to listen
to experts other than those in the sage
committee here's what he had to say
then on the sunday evening there was a
meeting with
a combination of sage scientists and
some
external people by this point
unfortunately
the prime minister was listening to
various people who were saying things
like
there's already heard immunity in the
population there won't be any second
wave etc etc
so we had this meeting in the cabinet
room sunday evening
patrick and chris gave their view um
john uh sorry um a guy called
hennigan uh and a woman from
um oxford called professor gupta i think
it was
gave the kind of don't lock down
view john edmonds
said he was on stage
surely we're going to learn the lessons
of march um here's what the data is
going to be
you are not going to the only logic of
not doing a
not doing a lockdown then will be that
you're not going to do it at all
there's no way you're going to make that
decision um
you know just do it now otherwise it's
all going to be worse
prime minister said i'm more persuaded
of that i'm delighted to have one of
those experts joining us now
sinitra gupta is professor of
theoretical epidemiology at the
university
of oxford thanks very much for joining
us on spectator
tv so what did you make of dominant
coming's account
of what you and other outsiders said to
the prime minister when you were called
in
last september i mean first of all in
general i would say it is unfortunate
that the level of discourse
surrounding all of this has settled into
a kind of personal harangue and a rant
and accusations fingers of blame being
pointed here and there
what i'd always hoped we would achieve
is a measured debate with different
sides being presented
now instead what's happened and what
we've had to endure and which has it
caused enormous damage
to science is this kind of partisan
debate with people blaming each other
constantly and we've had to suffer a
misrepresentation
of our ideas so for example when
uh dominic cummings said that we
or i had said that we had hit the herd
immunity threshold
this could not be further from the truth
uh all along
my position and it remains so is
that we cannot reliably calculate
a herd immunity threshold for
sales kirby ii and also that this
threshold fluctuates
due to seasonality but putting those two
ideas together you can explain what has
happened
in this country and many other countries
including india
as a kind of interaction between the
level of immunity that's acquired
already in the population and where the
herd immunity
threshold is at depending on the season
but we never said that we were at heard
immunity
um okay so that's one point yeah and i
think actually
we've got um the written evidence which
you gave to that
and and in that written evidence you say
quite clearly
that it's not say the funny thing about
covert is that you can't tell
when you return immunity um but
what was the overall car i mean right
now at that meeting
it was rare that people like you and
carl hennigan
it was dominantly coming as correct to
say that you were saying in effect
don't lock down now oh yes i think i
think that would be
a correct representation but that don't
lock down now
uh was not in response not because we
had already reached
herd immunity and therefore didn't need
to worry about a resurgence
don't lock down now was all about
whether lockdown is the appropriate
response and whether more lives
would not have been saved by employing a
complete or
a different strategy um which focused
on where protection was focused on those
right
but of course your proposal the great
barrington declaration effectively said
that the restrictions should be centered
or protection as you put it should be
centered
on people who are older and vulnerable
and not in the younger so you were
surely
advocating exactly the same thing let
younger people let the key workers if
you want go into society
basically let them get infected and this
was
i put to you a herd immunity strategy
and calling it
any other name is surely semantic and
deception
no i think that first of all i don't
think we should
even use the term herd immunity strategy
because herd immunity is not a strategy
it's um if you like it's part of our
tool kit in trying to
live with infectious diseases so we
should be thinking create you know
about how we can develop herd immunity
without paying that price
and of course vaccination is one of the
routes that we can do that
although whether covet vaccines will
allow us to reach herd immunities
another
question matter completely what we were
advocating
was in fact to shield the essential
workers who were at risk
of dying from kovid those who had
comorbidities
so um what instead we did we
what we did was we locked up the
university students
so i think it was there were strategies
that we could have put in place
which would have protected those who
were actually at risk of death
while allowing those who weren't at
significant risk of death
to conduct their lives normally and be
protected
from other forms of death and you know
deficits to the welfare um and which at
the same time would
lead as it has actually done to the
growth
of herd immunity in the population this
is for some reason people are in denial
of the fact that actually at the moment
one of the reasons we are enjoying
the situation we currently have is
because there has been
a substantial buildup of herd immunity
in the population
but you still find yourself in a
minority voice among scientists don't
you i mean
we heard from neil ferguson um imperial
college
um only earlier today where he basically
was saying
that the decision to delay lockdown by a
week cost
20 000 lives now that's just not him
seeing it from the top of his head
here several people very um well
regarded experts as imperial produced a
piece of work last december
making that exact calculation that
knowing what we know now from lockdown
delaying it by even a week
as the prime minister did in march when
he wasn't listening to dominic cummings
led to a death toll 20 000 higher than
it would otherwise have been that's a
scientific paper surely
um i don't to believe in those results i
think that
you can make a mathematical model in
which you embed a certain assumption
and then from that assumption you get a
certain result
and um i don't think that that was
a correct result furthermore um what
we suggested i think would have saved
more lives
so that's it's not as if we suggested
that you should do nothing
if you did nothing that would there
would be a
possibly a tangible difference between
going into lockdown
at least lockdown perhaps saves certain
lives
um but what we suggested was
going into a situation where we
protected those who might die
and allowed those who wouldn't die to uh
continue with their lives
and to prevent the uh
collateral damage that lockdown um
inevitably
but your theory is based on several
assumptions now
uh we've um i put to you that everybody
got things wrong but you included i mean
the
when quite often during the summer it
was it was said that you had for example
said that herd immunity was achieved
last march
and also i think you said in an
interview that the fatality ratio
would be closer to one in ten thousand
than one
in a thousand those things weren't true
were there
first of all in terms of with regard to
herd immunity
i don't think as i said before and i
keep saying
i don't think we know what level of herd
immunity was
achieved in may i can easily write down
a mathematical model
in which a high degree of herd immunity
or a large number of people were already
protected from
infection in may of course the herd
immunity threshold itself dropped
because of the summer
and so i would posit that in it was
immunity in the population that kept
um surges from occurring through the
summer
now my colleagues would disagree with me
and say no
it was a social distancing that kept um
numbers down but why would it come back
in the autumn i don't understand if her
immunity kept it down in the summer then
why would we see the second wave and
arguably the third wave when the kent
variant came along
first of all i did say in several
interviews that we would expect a winter
surge
the typical pattern of these respiratory
infections
is that the herd immunity threshold
itself
changes with time so in the summer you
have a low threshold of herd immunity
so even if a 25 of the population
happen to be immune that is sufficient
to prevent
the increase in infections as
the temperature drops and other
conditions change
that immunity threshold starts to creep
up
and that's why you inevitably will get a
winter surge
an autumn surge and possibly a spring
surge
these are all things that i said in
various interviews
not surprisingly people who choose to
discredit me
pick out one or two quotations
out of context which implied that i
thought the epidemic
was over the pandemic was over now all i
can say to you is if i thought the
pandemic was over
would i have spent the next six months
trying to come up
with a strategy um to handle a
resurgence
of this pandemic and what about the
fatality rates i mean
what's your estimate of that now okay
the fatality rate yes
so that was definitely careless of me to
say
that one in a thousand or ten thousand
is what the average
infection fatality rate is the truth is
that a mean
infection fatality rate is not a very
sensible number
to think about because it was a global
figure isn't there in a national figure
i mean there is some stage where
on a global basis it can be different to
what it is in a country where the virus
is trying to be controlled
it no in a country where the age
distribution is different where the
distribution is different you will get a
much much lower average
um infection fatality rate but it
because infection fatality rate is not
a fundamental property of a country it's
or the virus itself it's an uh it's a
property that relates to
the host age um condition i think what i
was
overzealously trying to draw attention
to was the fact that most of us
have a very very low likelihood of dying
from infection unless we are old frail
or have certain
comorbidities but certainly um i i
absolutely should not
have um put that number out there right
over the
that was not that's not correct but
overall listening to the seven hours of
dominant cummings
evidence seeing a world's worth of
experiments and lockdowns and also we've
got places like america where
texas took a very different um response
than california and they had sort of
comparable levels
of covet what do we think the
the jury obviously is out in lockdowns
but
um seeing what we see now do you do you
think that dominic cummings
is quite clear in saying that the delay
acting hard and lacking early
cost tens of thousands of lives are you
saying that you are pretty sure that he
is still
incorrect in that view i think first
i think he is incorrect but what's
really important here is that we don't
nobody should be saying anything with
certainty and the beauty of our focus
protection
plan is that it is robust to all these
uncertainties
regarding these uncertainties academics
should be having um resp you know
respectful
and um discussions debates
which has not been permitted really in
this whole um
saga but you know really what should be
happening is neil ferguson and i
should be having a publicized debate
uh where we present our assumptions talk
about our solutions
and you know come up maybe we won't
agree
we will respectfully agree to disagree
at the end of it
um what we've been trying to do
is come up with a plan that is robust
to these uncertainties and that is
focus protection is such a plan and the
beauty
of it now is that the vaccines allow us
to deliver focused protection without
getting into further debates about
how do we actually um implement it how
do we actually
um ask people to self-isolate over a
period of time when
the risk is high how do we separate
people in multi-generational households
all important problems to which i
think there were answers but now we have
a vaccine
which makes it really easy to deliver
focus protection
um so i think this whole
business of being certain and
particularly among
you know people who aren't experts in
the field to
have this certainty and exhibit this
rage
based on a certainty um it mystifies me
i would not have thought
this was how a civilized society
operates
well you certainly have been a victim of
this rage professor gupta and i wonder
at times
what on earth inspired you to go against
the consensus in the way that you did
in an atmosphere where dissenting voices
are um are hounded outs and indeed there
was a campaign to discredit you pretty
much run by
a tory mp neil o'brien who is um who was
after you did you not at times think
why did i bother or shouldn't i have
taken the more comfortable life i
imagine
things have been um pretty tough at
times for you
over the summer i wouldn't be surprised
if it doesn't mean some campaign to get
you to resign from university or
something like that
well yes of course it's been very tough
i mean
but but the truth is that i do feel i
have a responsibility
as a scientist and a citizen as a global
citizen
and i do feel very strongly that was
where i started and that's where i
remain
that the collateral damage from
lockdowns
is going to be is profound in its final
tally um we will be realizing that this
is just not an appropriate
tool that we have harmed young people
children and and um those
on low incomes and particularly people
in developing countries
to an extent that makes this
lockdown is just not an appropriate tool
and that's why we tried to come up with
other tools
that might be um appropriate and i still
believe
that focus protection uh is one of those
and now that we have a vaccine
it's possible to deliver that focused
protection
and i think that's what we should get on
with rather than um
trying to blame people and um
professor gupta thanks very much indeed
[Music]
you